l'assemblée nationale actuellement a
besoin vraiment d'être formaté parce
qu'actuellement on a une assemblée
nationale qui est mécanique qui est à la
baule de l'exécutif et qui ne joue
absolument pas son rôle nous voulons
donner une majorité absolue au coude
avec ce talent beaucoup plus
social que la prise de mousse
ken body works de manière arbitraire une
son élection sa moto a été scannée donc
moi je suis la tête de liste la religion
et surtout prenez le temps de lire les
propositions sont intéressantes derrière
voilà
[Musique]
m
ce matelas jolie se claque c'est un
symbole pour pour benno beaucoup yaka et
justement nous comptons bien sûr symbole
là parce que pour nous il n'y a pas de
fief
les sénégalais qui vivent à montre la
jolie sont des sénégalais comme tous les
autres
et l'important justement devenir
délivrer ce message là pour leur dire
que
nous nos aspirations connu concerne tous
les sénégalais donc l'idée c'est d'avoir
la majorité
va voter parce que c'est un droit
civique pour tout changer au gros tout
ce qui est un changement
parce que le changer mais pas à 100%
quoi
on est dans un tournant capital pour ne
devenir un pays on est dans un tournant
capital dans l'ambition que nous avons
pour conquérir le sénégal en 2024 parce
que ce dont il s'agit c'est qu'on a un
président qui veut s'éterniser au
pouvoir et on voit ses partisans dire
que s'il gagne ces élections
législatives là ils vont demander à
macky sall de se présenter pour un
troisième mandat et tous les sénégalais
épris de justice sachent qu'ils savent
que c'est définitivement interdit par
notre constitution donc pour le bien des
sénégalais pour le bien de tout le monde
il faudrait qu'ils donnent la majorité
absolue
à la coalition il ya eu askan wi
walou sénégal au soir du 31 juillet 2022
ça nous permettra d'être majoritaires
d'imposer à macky sall cette
cohabitation on voulait avoir la
majorité à la maintenance et à échelle
qu'est ce que vous proposez comme la
petite commence à composer trois est
vraiment très
bien travaillé on demandera ce qui passe
qui l'a fait au second tout le monde
sait
pour le prochain
mais beaucoup les réalisations parce que
depuis 1960 jusqu'à 1 et n'a que le
sénégal sont indépendants du talent
aucun président lancés comme le plus en
a qui sont ils assez
non
le fort parce que je sais que ça plus
difficile qu'en 2017 parce qu'en 2010
elle c'est la première fois que nous
disions donc non débuté et de position
était de viser cette fois ci donc il ya
une coalition dockers face nous la
respectons mais cela nous empêche pas de
faire notre travail donc elle n'a qu'à
faire ce qu'elle veut mais nous ce que
nous voulons au contact des sénégalais
expliquer le projet le podium excellent
en disant l'importance de ces élections
la cohabitation n'a jamais existé à
l'afrique ne voulons pas que le sénégal
soit le premier pays en afrique où ils
disent avoir une permutation
[Musique]
m